Uh,
yeah.
When you're arguing a point using logic,
you establish the premise
seeds to support a conclusion,
but many times your conclusion doesn't
actually follow from your line of
reasoning.
No matter how much you or your opponent
are convinced by your argument.
In that case,
you may be relying on a fallacy to
persuade yourself and your opponent.
This word fallacy sounds charged and can
certainly get tossed from side to side,
decided heated debates, but in logic of
fallacy is merely a descriptive term.
It says nothing about how dumb you are
nor about whether or not there exists
some real way to support the same
conclusion. Let me show you how it works.
I made an argument in the previous
video demonstrating that coffee isn't to
beverage but a food.
In this argument,
I relied on two distinct meanings of the
word coffee and two different meanings
of the word beans in my premises.
I was intentionally vague and used
compact language to hide these choices.
The simple language makes the argument
much more convincing than if I disclosed
the intended meaning of these words.
The result,
the conclusion looks like it
follows from the premises,
but it's really not supported by them.
The conclusion may or may not be true,
but it's uncalled for here.
This reliance on the
psychological persuasiveness
of a statement is a hallmark
feature of informal fallacies,
which are informal because
the truthfulness of the
conclusions content can't be
derived from the truthfulness
of the content of the premises.
Still the arguments for may be perfectly
valid. Like my food is coffee syllogism.
Here's some examples
of informal fallacies.
Okay.
Hm Hm hm hm hm hm hm hm hm hm
hm
hm.
The list goes on it all cases,
informal fallacies,
rely of content that does something other
than support the conclusion in order
to get you to accept the conclusion,
you can get a feel for how the logic
of the supporting line of reasoning
actually runs. If you just remove
the fallacious statement like this,
not so reasonable.
Now is it recall that arguments
don't just have content.
They also have form.
We called an argument with well
structured premises into conclusion.
So it may not surprise you to hear of
a formal fallacies which arise when we
shape the argument in a way
that the conclusion doesn't
follow from the premises.
But people can still be persuaded by the
conclusion because it seems to follow.
Let's play around with a few arguments
to see if you can spot weaknesses in
their form in their
structure. First, a refresher,
a basic syllogism. A is
B, B is c, so a is c.
Fill it in as you like. We've
seen that this form works. Next,
a second point of reference and an
even simpler argument if p then Q,
p,
therefor Q.
This is a basic reasoning strategy
and it works. What about this one?
A is not B. B is not
c. Therefore a is. See,
think about it for a moment and check
against other examples if you need to.
The first premise only
supports that a is not B.
So anything we say about being the second
premise can't apply to a positively or
negatively. The conclusion
doesn't follow. This.
Next one runs aground on the same
issue as the last. A is not B.
So no matter what we say about B,
it doesn't apply to a
what's wrong here. I've negated
P in this conditional statement,
then assumed that Q must also be negated,
but perhaps Q is conditioned
on something else.
Spot the problem here
yet. No, look closer.
Keep looking because you won't find it.
This one's good and I leave it to you
and your clever ways to figure out why.
One more for you.
Can I argue that what follows from a
conditional implies what proceeds consider
this form carefully.
A implies B only states that
if a holds B also holds,
it does not mean that.
Be always follows from a come on.
You remember your logical by conditionals,
right?
That's all for fallacies. Well,
for this introduction to fallacies,
I'm sure you will encounter plenty more.
These last two topics introduced arguments
and fallacies and I'll add them to my
playlist for the intro to logic.
If you're visiting the youtube channel
and to the lesson page on native
wayne.com I hope you've enjoyed a bit
more light TV. Thanks for learning.